[Music]
inside Victoria Beckham's engagement
ring style collection of jewelry I make
the best of what I've of what I've got
the 44 year old fashion mogul and her
husband David Beckham are celebrating 19
years of marriage in 2018 and the former
Spice Girl has accumulated quite the
jewellery collection since the former
soccer pro proposed in 1998 including a
whopping 14 different engagement style
rings you know I just think it's fun you
know fashion should be fun and it's
about finding new ways of wearing things
it all started when David popped the
question in 1998 with this stunning
marquise cut diamond reportedly worth
$85,000 nearly four years after saying I
do Victoria was spotted sporting an
emerald cut diamond jewel on that finger
during the 2003 MTV Movie Awards we
didn't love each other like we did when
we first met though the stones have
changed shapes and sizes throughout the
years none has stood out more than the
gorgeous pair cut sparkler the mama 4
debuted in June 2007 I love a bit of
grace ha Victoria's most unique and
dainty bauble yet this emerald cut
yellow diamond that she was seen rocking
in June 2018 at the Dior menswear spring
summer 2019 runway show at Paris Fashion
Week
[Music]
et sat down with the fashionista last
year or she couldn't help the gush over
her man he's my soul mate and we really
support each other I am so proud of him
he's such a good kind person he's the
most fantastic dad supporting husband as
well and were partners
[Music]
[Applause]